- I don't really feel anything yet.
- (laughs) Then take another one.
(epic music)
- Le Petite Crepe.
- I don't really feel like reading.
- Ok.
- Oh, Enemy Buds?
- No, Kevin James reminds me of my Dad.
What about Man Child 2?
- I don't really like
lowest common denominator stoner comedies.
- No.
- Can you go and get the tickets for me?
- No, you owe me money!
- Hi, could I get-- (laughs)
I got two for Space Reindeer.
- Why?
Ugh, it's Dreamworks.
- Tickets?
- Uh, yeah.
Hey, Brittany, do you have the tickets?
- No, you have the tickets.
- I can't seem to find them.
- Do I have the tickets?
- I just had them.
- Do you have my phone?
- These people saw me, you saw me, I--
- I lost my phone.
- Ok, um--
- Where are they?
Retrace your steps!
- Oh, I got them.
They're right here.
- Enjoy your show.
- You too!
- I can't stop smiling.
- I'm really starting to feel it now.
I hope I don't run in to anyone I know.
- Is that Brittany?
Brittany Ashley?
Oh my gosh, we keep
running in to each other!
Oh hey man, how are you?
- Hi, yeah.
- Yeah, I was just taking
Artemio's little brother
out to see a movie.
We're seeing Space Reindeer!
- Oh my God, we're seeing Space--
- Man Child 2.
Uh, so we definitely
can't sit next to you,
I have to find my phone
and use the bathroom.
Ok, I gotta go.
- Both of us have allergies,
contact lens problems,
we were crying a lot too, so.
- Yeah we were crying a lot today too.
He's the strongest little guy I know.
- I think I took too much.
It's like, oh, and it's
just now kicking in?
Am I going to be this high forever?
Kevin James...
Can you overdose on weed?
- Oh hey cool hat by the way!
(laughs) We actually picked up
a couple of these too.
These'll be our movie hats, huh, bud?
(explosion)
- He's the strongest little kid I know.
- Cool.
- I've gotta find Chris.
- No movie could be
better than that preview.
(movie soundtrack)
- Sorry to leave you hanging,
he was really creepy.
- Oh, your friend Chris?
He seems fine.
- Artemio would have loved this CGI.
That's Hitchcock's Vertigo zoom.
I don't know if he's watching the film,
I think he just likes being a dark room.
(peppy music)